Gary I asked you yesterday after the
ultimate moves event how are you feeling
and you said that I'm feeling the pieces
right now you definitely showed that in
today's games and I have to say that
last game it was just a masterpiece give
us your emotions right now look you know
I
I think that somehow you know I'm
receiving back you know the points that
I lost last year is it because it's if
you remember the the first day last year
or so I had a bad problem slightly
better game against live on which I lost
very very badly and then to winning
positions against uh farby uh first I
guess
so I started zero out of three so I
think it had a huge effect on me so what
happened what's happening now is that I
decided that you know I have to cross my
hand is this my brains are not as fast
as it used to be but hand is still there
you know so and uh the last game you
mentioned just you know I knew it was
right so this is yeah just I played very
quickly at the end because everything
went you know just in the right position
you know found every piece found the
right spot so that's the end uh but
again I felt very good because the first
game was definitely was very important
so like I was still
not uncomfortable but just to be tensed
and it was really serious game I mean
this is he just you know it's it looked
position looked equal but you know he he
always created threats and and then I
just you know Instinct the way I decided
so I could go for this risk because you
know I wouldn't play H3 I actually like
yes it's the yes this is the yeah it's
the
yeah so the yeah that's importantly is
at the mid Castle here this which is you
know it's interesting because I played
94 provokes history so just say I'm
always
creative but still you know it's a
little bit dangerous because you know
black is behind Poland's hanging but you
know uh but here is just you know I can
easily go it's the stakehold F4 so H3
and now I just you know I I have to say
that I'm I I missed you know for queen
d395 queen C2 so that was just this
which one e for Queen this is 95 95 and
then I saw Queen C2 yeah and then D4
yeah so this is yes yeah this is yeah
it's terrible so I just I um and uh um
which again this is It's the um I uh I
think it's just it's the uh
uh yeah it's funny that it's it's
actually here it's probably this move F3
in this position yes yes still a free so
that's that's something take F2 okay
Bishop F5 check
yes yeah that then then can be eight
and you're still hanging on I'm still I
think I still hanging again that's just
a little bit of tonight this way
slightly worse
it's not that good so it's the uh and I
just yeah
I sensed Bishop A6 problem holding
problem again it's it's very the bishop
B6 you know it took on C6 Knight F3 it
just says yes this isn't it and that's
neither free and I just you know it's if
you if you if you want to go go because
the move that you want to do now is
something like Queen Queen D7 but then I
just said oh I wasn't sure what happens
after after Queen A6 maybe that's the
best and then and they're rookie for her
rookie four maybe C5 a knight D5 Queen
production it's not G5 that's what I was
afraid ah but that's that's bad yes
Bishop to D5 Bishop D5 yes yes I guess
you hide this one yes so but maybe that
was the best but I just sensed that you
know I could go between B7 yeah and I
was very interesting because you know
when you played um Queen E4 uh I mean
eventually was but I saw on the bishop
P5 yes and it's it and I saw that if he
goes which is that I go immediately they
come to counter push Queen the seven
Queen distribution with five so again
here dangerous position again visually
but Bishop but you're feeling safe
and the moment you know I change all
these good pieces especially what we do
and my Bishop potentially when he had a
dream that one I said maybe one you know
when people have a C3 in the world maybe
I play Queen history
Dream came through yes that's it that's
it that's that's an obituary and that's
pretty much it yeah that's that's that's
it so that's the um and um and I think
as a second round so I just you know
it's like whiskey koru you know it
looked for me that's the opening was
good so that's it but it's the when what
yes you see d593 you special by the way
it's out of time yeah but yeah but what
to do I mean just I don't know what I
just it's the probably you should start
playing something slowly Queen B2 Bishop
D3 so that's again it's just
maybe bishop D2 I wasn't sure can I do
that Bishop D2 man sorry but maybe yeah
because you're actually agrees with your
decision just take on the five exchange
like that yeah it's only a slight flat
Edge but it was not true but this is the
eventually I won the pawn which is again
it's it's yeah I just had a little
pressure but uh yeah actually I just
Bishop before I missed by the distance
but he just made a very strong move
Knight C4 of course yeah very important
just you know he gave up the opponent
and here I just thought okay I have an
extra poem but you know I'm not probably
better yes yeah and but you know it's
it's a time should I try to bring or
just today and I just I couldn't make a
decision and I just got in real trouble
I think the end game will stop the Lost
yeah oh clearly lost him but I just was
very proud because Hikaru is I I found
the study like draw at the end now the
end game is is really is bad I mean you
felt bad about it
instead of you for F5 and four you know
you could have put problems like this
was perhaps the moment early without
having Google 94 Rook D3 and basically
bringing only five I didn't see this
King goes only five so this is this is
the I just want to provoke his Rook
because otherwise King was only five at
five and four there's nothing I can do
that's that's yeah
and he decided I think I think when he
just moved this is Rook you know
suddenly and then in order since I found
I just because I calculated F4 and it's
first you know I saw take take take yes
yes
I just thought King D6 King District C5
yes King this kicks A4 is the draw but
that is a king D5 A4 King D5 but he's
winning yes this is he's winning h4a5
yes and and he also saw it yes but King
C3 is a study light move so I I was very
proud that's that's an immediate draws
no absolutely you are actually blitzing
out through this movement
10 seconds left yes but again
yeah so that's this is just you remember
this is it's all it's all worked out and
so this I have to ask you about the last
game because the last game by the way I
I have to I don't know what's the
impression on I think this is the worst
position for black opening position we
ever had okay open position I don't know
what was the outcome this is because
it's the the DeForest I think C4 is very
dangerous this is what Levon said as
well I think what's foreign yeah
yeah but that's the yeah and he was
probably yeah but we'll get this
position plus one plus one this position
is real after I see four I would
probably play G6 G6 probably G6 because
I couldn't we couldn't find anything
with Wesley and Hikaru so this is it's
probably worse it's probably the worst
position that for black that is just we
ever had this is this is definitely
should be marked some of the positions
should be probably marked because it's
really unpleasant right so he played D4
which is also interesting so D4 and um
and the it's the because it's also yes
D4 D5 yes and uh yeah okay you're gonna
play E4 and I and I think I just buy all
the move with E5 I wasn't sure it's
ed5 cd5 I'm not sure it's the it's oh
yeah this is terrible yeah Bishop D7 I
thought maybe I still can hold
there you go and I guess you're just
like one move away 84 yeah can I take on
D4 maybe look uh H okay uh that's the
that's the machine that just get exactly
that's steam yeah I thought maybe I
could have hold but but E4 H4 was also
dangerous but then I think I just found
I found a really good maneuver the
defensive one of the Bishops like we did
yeah 97 yes e396 Bishop D3 take take 26
Bishop he registered I thought about I
could have taken an F5 I mean that's why
I spent time interesting H2
but and if he goes castles but kingly
two King E2 maybe that's unpleasant
because the castle of this side no
Castle because then then you cannot trap
my queen after A6 and I G3 H4 Rook H1
doesn't work because a free square is
still working yes but I wasn't sure as
this it still may be possible yes but
there's the but the reason to take on F5
just you know to make sure the queen
cannot go on G4 because after Queen A5
Bishop F5 Queen takes a five
yeah Queen takes A5 here uh E6 yeah you
you don't have the same comfortable
square footage war is coming yeah but
it's also maybe Queen free Bishop E7
so that's this because my position is
old but I wasn't sure about Knight xf5
yeah yeah it's a small timing yeah and
and uh but that's okay I can just play
H4 and and it's and that's that was a
very important E6 E5 it's only move
because I have to play five now no no no
I play E6 E6 and then E5 yeah and yeah I
could play probably immediately A5 also
just you know I wasn't sure because the
idea is Queen E6 key is a queen E6
quizzes yes I wasn't sure what what's
there what's the right move but somehow
I sense that you have this D5 and F4 is
looks winning but after Queen deserved
four star white has a strategic risk so
the idea being that 97 97 and then
Castle G6 and it's the and that's yes
and white is in trouble and yeah exactly
yeah wonderful way and this is this yeah
he's missing one Temple but I'm black
and castle Yeah there's a safely Castle
you still have cancer so he just he took
there and I think I just I played the
end game I play well yeah it's five
nights rookie doesn't put now it's
interesting you know this because it's
all You'll Play F6 G6 but it's too early
it's you just to fix the problem five
but it's too early you have to take the
bishop away take E4 Square I already saw
this all the squares you know yeah all
the squares yeah this is and then that's
just you don't need to take points he
had no moves yeah no moves yes
I mean this must be
yep yeah beautiful finishes yeah it's a
good game yes again I I I I don't know
what will happen tomorrow so but yeah I
enjoy I enjoyed it and um and uh again
if I keep this in the same correct
balance between the hand and brains so I
can do well yeah sir Nazi join the
conversation
congratulations Gary I mean no seriously
it's wonderful to see you uh playing
successfully still though Gary if I can
reprimand you your time management you
still need to work on that
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes there's
always room for improvement
work on it good luck tomorrow yeah
fantastic thank you thank you absolutely
thank you Gary it's one half out of
three but there is still room for
improvement